what
universe is that kid alive dude
universe is that kid alive
what is the main reason you prefer cs
over valorant like the thing i've always
really liked about counter-strike
whether it's go or 1.6 and really well i
was going to say source but that's not
quite true
unless your way you want to express
yourself is just holding w and
pretending every gun is the spectre
counter strike just has more
sophisticated movement and shooting and
it just allows you to ex like express
yourself in in better ways like you
wanna you know what i mean like
oh it's
case and point kids
[Music]
easy for ants or flash bang dance which
is more of a banger i actually do sort
of think that flashbang dance is a huge
banger a lot of my friends get really
annoyed with the easy friends one i
don't i actually still think it's really
good every time i hear it